I watched the Golden Globes last night
for example no political speeches no
virtue signaling no grandstanding people
basically did what Ricky Jas told them
to do three years ago which is get up
thank your agent and and sit down is
this a sign Jordan do you think of a
real backlash and that even Hollywood
has woken up to the reality that they
don't want to hear this stuff all the
time the mistake that entertainers make
is that they regard what they do as mere
entertainment Hollywood stars and all
the people who were involved in
producing the narratives that entice and
and compel us they're serving a master
who's High far higher than anything
merely political the art should never be
subordinated to serve the political
because then it gets not only does it
get propagandistic it gets dull you get
these hysterical people that they think
because they can pretend to be an
astronaut in a movie they can also also
tell you how to live your life